[Music]
you have a glass a coaster a cigarette
and a quarter stacked on top of each
other can you get the quarter in the
glass without touching the glass coaster
cigarette or quarter what-what-what-what
[Music]
I can't touch anything I was gonna say
cuz I could just go fling and it'd be
done
wait I can't so I can't touch anything
so I have to get the coaster out of the
way the cigarette out of the way and
then only the quarter kind knock it over
I just have to do something without
doing anything that sounds easy I'll do
that I have to like be like the big bad
wolf and like blow it down I'm just
gonna throw the table across the room
and hope for the best
oh maybe if I shake it oh okay can I
touch the table no I can probably
breathe at it I'm glad there's like not
fire involved is there fire involved I'm
going for the same reproach can other
stuff go into the cup too like is it
okay just the cue I actually am like
there's no way in hell you can do this
little shake to the left little stick to
the right for those of you who are
wondering I know there's gonna be a lot
of comments about this this is a
Delaware quarter no [ __ ] idea I have
no idea I think I'm a shaken I'm gonna
check it one more time just like this
for hunts like this to say I did it
[Music]
what the hell this is insane I give up I
give up this is stupid
I don't know I really I really have no
idea I give up I have no idea so maybe
if I blow up the bottom part of it oh my
god
move lower see here about eye level with
the table then blow up under the coaster
this will move the coaster and the
cigarette while the quarter drops into
the glass that's pretty good
oh my god so I went on the right track
with blowing it I didn't do it with
enough gumption how I was trying to do
that exactly but I was trying to blow
that off this is stupid
[Music]